assalamu alaikum greetings and peace how
are you guys doing welcome to the dean
show i'm eddie your host
and as always we have an exciting
program with you
this topic is very sad it's something
that really brings tears to the heart
the heart could
cry be exploding the bombs have stopped
falling
but have the children stop dying we have
so much to talk about here
and there's someone that we're going to
bring on a palestinian someone who's
actually in palestine
and we want him to go ahead and also
help respond to another palestinian
who actually has a lot to say on
palestine
the topic of palestine and israel so
let's go ahead and watch this video then
we're going to bring our surprise
guest out to respond to
this individual by the name you know him
by nas
daily so let's go ahead and
listen to this
this is exactly why like life is too
short to to spend years on a conflict
like um i i'm not i don't
care about a piece of land so a lot of
jews care about israel because you know
homeland
a lot of palestinians care about al-aqsa
because it's religion
but i don't care about either
um myself
and our guest here peace activist
how are you hi how are you salaam
thank you for joining us here on the
dean show brother thank you for hosting
me
are you familiar with nas nas daily yes
who's not
yes so what do you think did you do we
need to play the video again or did you
get a chance
to to uh hear it well here we are
familiar with
with nasa's work uh and mainly we don't
need
to listen to one of his videos in order
to to know his arguments
and because we know his type of people
it's the problem is not nas the problem
is everybody who has
the same ideology or doesn't have an
ideology in the first place
so the the problem with with people like
nasdali that we believe in that
i think the guy suffers from a great
stockholm or
or his we we call his type people who
already left
the palestinian cause and they are not
uh they are not
in with us anymore the
his his let's say his way of thinking
and way of speaking is the worst
thing that happened to the prostate
cause ever just because he was born of a
palestinian family i don't believe he is
palestinian anymore
the the palestinian cause is a fight for
freedom and for
for pride and for liberation and for
human rights in the first place
and whenever you leave that you leave
some of your biggest values
or your main values as a human in the
first place
uh the problem with people like naz
the story didn't start with us and it's
not us that that's our fighting it's not
my generation or what i
dream of being or what i wanna what is
my future and my goals the problems
this what he calls conflict is
occupation and this occupation has
started 72 years ago and before way
before that
the palestinian people were killed
in their home places were kicked out of
their houses and villages
and were refugees into other countries
and their grandsons are today living
in refugee camps suffering from the
worst situations
in the world today maybe people in gaza
are are under siege
they don't have any main living or
basics
that they can have a good life apartheid
in the 48 areas where i live
discrimination and persecution by the
israeli police
the the interfering with the muslim
priors in al-aqsa
maine human rights are not here so
that's
not a fight we can give up we are not
giving the option to give up or to live
any other type of fight because
occupation is forcing us to fight in the
first place and because
out of our humanity we would never leave
that
let me let's hear this again i i'm not i
don't care
about a piece of land so a lot of jews
care about israel because you know
homeland
a lot of palestinians care about al-aqsa
because it's religion
but i don't care about either
um myself
that's very empty it's very yeah it
seems like
okay it's just some land what's the big
deal give up some land and live your
life yes
that's that's such an empty conversation
he had there and then and then at the
end it's very interesting
that he says and you know um i just care
about myself
yes that's it i mean is it that
simplistic that's just hey give up some
land and uh we can go about business can
you talk about
how is how is the um the situation there
for the
for the average i mean we hear often uh
this is a democracy here you know
equal rights for all but how is the
day-to-day life
for the palestinian there palestinian
christian palestinian muslim
you know how are they living are they
able to we hear that the scarcity of
water electricity health care education
that uh open your prison that they're
like in a jail
with just big walls so is it that
is it that simplified just give up some
land and live your life life's too short
well it's a bit different from one area
to an area but what i can say for all
palestinians that no we're not living a
basic human right
life the the thing the thing nasa's
saying in that video is that if you
forget about your palestinianship and if
you forget about the history of your
people and if you forget about your
cause
you can can live a good life in israel
and you can make
money you can make businesses you can
make stuff i
come from a society called the makkah
the bedouin palestinians who live
in the south of occupied palestine
israel today
after the year 48 90 of my people were
kicked
for the from the people of danaka were
kicked out of
uh out of the the arab countries and
only ten percent stayed in here today we
are 300
000 people living in here 140 000 of
these people
are living in unrecognized villages
these are towns
with that people with israeli citizens
citizenships
living there and due to international
law
laws they should have same basic rights
same rights as
jews and as israel is living in in the
country but 140 000 people of these
people live
in 36 unrecognized villages with no
electricity no water no
basic structures in the past five years
only around 11 000
houses and more eleven thousand houses
were demolished in one
area uh the houses of these people my
people the bedouins
and unlock only uh where are you here
in this where do you reside around which
area you're here somewhere on the map
right
you're yeah
you can see where the word palestine in
the green map is written in all of them
yes yeah palestine the green map it's
there i'm there
so what does this map signify what does
this tell us for the person layman has
no idea
you know what does this tell us what
does it say to you well this is the
occupation of palestine how it started
and how it got into today before the
year 484 token history for the year 48
the the the jews came in here like
refugees from the holocaust and from the
terror that happened to them
in india in the european countries and
the palestinian people accepted them
and hosted them all on the shores and
opened their houses for them at the time
because they were refugees suffering
and the society earned snow and it's
certainly in history it's well
documented
that everybody has hosted them and
giving them a place to live
because these were people who are
suffering in the reality but year after
year after year after year the zionist
dream became
creating and was very obvious for us
that they are creating a country over
our country they are demolishing us in
order
to to build their their their country
the israeli occupation at the time they
didn't want to be partners until and
even though they were coming and we
hosted them
in the first place but then they took
peace after peace after peace after
peace until they
created this very uh they were awful
occupational
uh colonialist settlements regime that
we are living in today
you actually wrote about you did a
response an academic response
you wrote a paper an article is that
true on this next video we're about to
see
yes we did it's it wasn't about the
video
specifically about the video but his
version of speaking about about the look
up like we chose
what you're going to see in the video
that we chose this like this was forced
on us
and that we accept our faith and that we
are staying in our lands
even though when you go to abedwan
living in the desert you ask him
me as a bedouin asking my brother what
do you want
from to change in here he would say i
just want israel to not demolish my
house that's the idea
we don't have much to lose but we don't
want to win anything from occupation
we want to live with electricity with
water with with townships and with
uh with health services but we don't
want to leave our homes and our
lands original lands for that so we'll
go ahead and watch this that's really
powerful i just don't want my home
taken away demolished i just want food i
want water i want basic human rights
wow i want a proud life
when i grew up i thought everybody
wanted a better life
and better meant living in a big city
like new york with fast internet
good weather and a nice ferrari but wake
up from the dream
this is exactly the opposite of what i
want and it's where i
am it's a hut in the middle of the
desert
with no internet insane heat and instead
of ferraris
there are chicken donkeys camels cats
goats and sheep
this is the life of bedouins the nomads
who live
and love the simple but hard life known
for being generous
hospitable and the most respectful of
guests with no desire to get the latest
iphone
or macbook
it's hard for me and you to live this
life or
want it but to that they say
so what was the the main thing here you
were saying that people even here who
are
living a good life meaning that they're
happy and content with what they have
even places like this they can get their
homes
taken away of course
so the israeli the zionist mentality in
a lot of believes
that uh the land of allah should not be
owned by arabs
so the problem is that they try to kick
us out of their land or they prevent us
from having
like they would in the first place they
wouldn't give you any services again
they wouldn't give you a permission to
build the house
they wouldn't give you water flowing to
you to your house they wouldn't give you
electricity if you want electricity in
your house you should
put solar panels and buy them on your or
your own expense if you want water
if you don't fill tanks and bring them
next to your home and
buy the water yourself and like bring
the tank and put it
you can buy from the israeli water
company
three times or four times uh the price
that
people jewish people pay in in their
villages for example
so the idea they wouldn't give you
services in order for you to leave the
the area but we are satisfied with our
land we don't have a problem living
hardships
just what is the main goal of this life
that we are doing why are we so patient
because we believe this is our land
we are under occupation true this is one
day
leaving this is one day is going to be
over that doesn't mean i'm leaving my
land i'm not going to exchange my land
for for water and electricity but that
doesn't mean i don't want them i believe
that i
that i have original original rights on
my land i should get these services
uh due to international law and due to
basic law and due to the israeli
laws as an israeli citizen but they are
giving not giving me that i didn't
choose not to get that
but i've been here i'm staying here on
my land i'm always going to be
here as much as they try to kick us out
when they prevent the services from you
then they
demolish your house and you have stories
in al-nakha
like the al-araki village was demolished
188 times
and people still keep rebuilding their
houses on their places
[Music]
it's six am but i have finally arrived
to my home
in israel but every time i mention the
word israel or palestine i get in
trouble
in the comment section there is no
israel
there is no palestine you don't so to
settle this issue
here is where i stand i am a palestinian
israeli 69 years ago
when israel came into existence some
palestinians left
some got killed and some stayed in their
lands
my people stayed and for the next 70
years we lived under
israel there are two ways i can live my
life one i say israel does not exist
and i come only from palestine or two i
accept the borders of israel and i
accept the new borders of palestine
and i move on i choose number two to
move on
because in life there are better and
bigger things to focus on
than the name of a piece of land there
is an israel and there is a palestine
i grew up in israel right next to
palestine and i'm jet lagged
that's one minute see you tomorrow
okay seems like he's got the answer what
do you think i mean uh
seems like uh he's got a solution here
what do you think of his solution
brother this guy has the worst
terminology i've ever seen in my life
like the first the first problem with
what he says
i'm leaving the whole idea and what he's
suggesting and the first problem with
with
his speech is his terminology it wasn't
the existence of israel it was the
occupation of palestine
it wasn't uh it wasn't the country that
was built out of nothing it was a
country that was took out of its people
and people were trying to decide their
fate at the time
uh palestine was was a working mechanism
the people were developing and trying to
get out of one occupation in order to
build their own
their own life we were ruled by the
british we were occupied by by the
british regime at the time
but people in jaffa and then haifa and
then bear saber were building their own
life you had newspapers coming out you
had theaters you had cinnamon
you had people working you had four four
million boxes of orange that
being produced in jaffa and were sold to
to to europe and the place here was
known
it's not only a piece of land it's
culture it's uh
it's a heritage it's uh it's it's
our proud pride as a people that was
taken and that we are fighting to
retrieve
uh it was never a piece of land and him
thinking about it as a piece of land so
i think he is the one who should leave
it uh the
the ethical problem the ethical burden
is not on the occupied it's on the
occupier in the palestinian because
first place can you can you fill us in
on what's going on with masjid al-aqsa
right now
we saw earlier during the month of
ramadan
the soldiers storming in there throwing
the stun grenades you know fires
we saw all sorts of havoc you know has
things calmed down what's the situation
with alma
aksa it's more quiet now but that
doesn't mean that they're
like people are being the uh the
jerusalem people
see you are being punished in the
streets understood i have
i had a few friends who were arrested in
the past few weeks and me myself was
arrested and my little brother
uh after the alaska event and after the
whole
are 48 events that that happened in the
past few weeks
we had a very intense few weeks with the
war in gaza and israeli crimes
on gaza at the time what happened what
started all of this for example of
course
everybody heard about i think the case
of
genre these are uh these are the houses
of palestinians
uh for palestinian families around 500
palestinian families
that the israeli government is trying to
kick them out a bit
in order to put settlers in their place
and that's a very
very known apartheid scenario that
happens in israel all the time it
happened here in danaka by
by kicking the people of homolharan a
bedouin town and building this is the
settlement of iran on their place that's
happening
right now also so what's happened what
happened in al-aqsa started from
uh the israeli government trying to uh
to bring all the time they are like
supporting the settler organizations
that they are
achieving the uh the zionist mentality
of having a jewish accent jewish
and jewish jerusalem at the time israeli
jerusalem
zionist jerusalem so every year they try
to bring
settlers inside our worshipping place uh
the muslim
though the muslim part laksamasa art
so it's a main right for palestinians
and muslims to not agree to settlers
who steal their lands and who burn
palestinian villages and who are coming
in there out of
uh making us feel bad and making uh
making it normal for them to steal the
al-aqsa from us and to steal areas from
al-aqsa
so every year they try to do that we
don't agree to that and we
we have always been saying that and as
it's no international law al-aqsa
is an international area this area is
not this quarter is not
an israeli in the first place and the
whole city of jerusalem
so the israeli government tried to bring
settler in there
when the people said no it started
bombing people and shooting rubber balls
i was photographing there at the time
and i've seen the atrocities
that the israeli government has really
posted to the people they entered inside
the alaska
axons gassed people and
they shot people with rubber bullets and
they were
assaulting people on on the grounds and
and when they are handcuffed also
what do you say to the to the common
reiterated
statement that look this is for the
safety of israel and these palestinians
are terrorists they're terrorizing us
and we're just trying to protect
ourselves we need to survive
have you have you do you often hear this
yes we do we do
we are we're here in the past few weeks
there are 48 people the palestinians who
have israeli citizenship so stayed here
after
they we were lynched in the streets we
were chased by settlers we
we had we had settlers shooting at our
houses
and trying to get not children from
their from their towns
and looking surging rooming the uh the
guild cities there the arab jewish
cities in order to find
arabs to beat them in the street the
israeli
the israeli police would give them
protection we're talking about israelis
we're talking about uh them these
settlers are looking for arabs who have
israeli citizenship let's talk
let's not talk about the palestinians
but we are all the presidents that's how
the israeli government sees us
and that's who we are in the first place
so the problem is not
uh me being muslim or palestinian the
problem is
that this is the zionist mentality uh
these settlers
search for us in the streets and when
they find their
they they lynch that herb and they beat
the arab in the street they killed they
killed musa
in a lid and they killed er
they killed another shahid and and
normal
the the problem here is that they are
being protected by the police and they
are also fulfilling
police even ministers of israel said
that this is
they are continuing the work of the
israeli forces and the israeli
the israeli police so it's it's it's an
apartheid regime it's a big system
it's a democracy for the jews and
they're what they see
what they want to do is to make it a
fully israeli
zionist jewish state when you see this
statement from
a former us president jimmy carter is
this pretty on point
when israel territory deep within the
west bank and connects the two
or so 200 soul settlements with each
other
with a road and then prohibits the
palestinians from using that road
or in many cases even crossing that road
this
perpetuates even worse instances of
apart
tightness or apartheid than we witness
even in south africa
what do you think of this statement we
lived that
yeah when we're reading about this south
african experiment
experience irani apartheid is true
apartheid is here
and the problem is that these white
people are much smarter
smarter than the other white people that
were in in south africa
yes what about what about the children
we see why we see a lot of children
being kidnapped
from their families young young children
what's going on with that
in the past three weeks dean more than 3
000
are palestinians from the 48 areas were
arrested and then only my area more than
60 to 70 percent
of the people who were arrested were
children using the children
is a way to to scare the families and
put
pressure on them all most of the
children like
maybe 90 percent of them will come out
of the jail and the grown-ups this is
but let's talk about the truth
they competing their their
bones will be broken they will have
injuries in their faces
and they will be put in jail and put in
there for weeks even if they don't have
any proofs on them
so it's a way to scare the people so it
puts pressure on the families
but alhamdulillah people are are
patient so
tell us uh we often hear this
in this area the um
area of j what is it called jafar
the area where they're evicting the
palestinians sheikh
sheikh jafar
this area the the common excuse is that
look
we're the landlords are evicting the
tenants so we rented this out
and now hey it's they didn't pay their
rent
so we're evicting them so this is what
everyone in the mainstream is usually
hearing what do you say to that to that
these people build built their houses in
there
these houses they built with their hands
they
they were there well it's it's
the problems with the basics
those browser the basics the whole land
of palestine and then to solve the
problems we also should go
always to the basics the whole land of
the palestinian people
was taught in the year 48 was occupied
by the israeli police
the people were kicked or killed from
their homes
uh and this ethnic cleansing that
happened in the year 4k
is continuing until today and they are
kicking people out of their houses or to
make it as jewish as they can
you saw that you saw that map that makes
how small palestine palestinian areas
are today
and how big they were before and how
much was taking from us they are
trying to narrow that and to make it
smaller and smaller all the time
yeah and there is something important
sorry about jerusalem
the problem is not only there are today
there are around four neighborhoods
arab neighborhoods in jerusalem that the
people in there are being evicted
and the israeli court and the israeli so
the israeli police is trying to evict
the people but then
you would have to go to the israeli
court who the judge is also a settler
and just trying to evict you in the
first place there's nowhere
for the palestinians to go but there are
another
three three three neighborhoods that are
the israeli government is trying to
evict
and they are putting pressure every day
on the people they are trying to kick
the people out
before and it's very important to know
that before they try to kick the people
out they try to buy their homes
they pay tens of millions of shekels for
the people to have their houses but the
people don't leave their houses and they
don't
uh sell it to the jews when they cannot
buy the houses from the people
so how can i affect you if i'm i'm in
the first place admitting that it's your
house i'm trying to buying it from you
when you're not selling me i bring the
israeli the police and the israeli army
to take you out of the house and they
put
there in your place so there are more
than one neighborhood
uh in jerusalem and inside the old city
of jerusalem it happened a lot you go
to the laksa mask and you see how many
houses they already stole how many
houses
they kick the people out of them there
are houses that are very stuck to the
to the lobster mosque and you have
israeli flags on them and they are
where they have well heavily guarded
with families of settlers they are
trying to make it a jewish
to make the muslim court in jewish court
and i
feel some people do without religious
reasons not for me
and for the people of palestine we know
it's not religious at all it's a
national fight he's fighting us because
we're arabs
they're trying to make it a zionist area
as much as they can trying to delete our
history to make us out of the existence
that what they do all the time
by covering our our refugee towns that
they kicked us out of them
and by by covering the history and
trying to change the story all the time
when it comes to media when it comes to
the places to the names of the streets
to they don't want us to be here
and they're trying to cover even that we
were here in the first place and we are
staying
just a few more uh questions we're
almost out of time have you heard this
term the third temple
and last time we had our guest uh mikko
pillad
he's also israel he's israeli jewish
he's an activist somebody
um who is he's a great friend
yeah he's a friend of yours also yes and
he talked about that this was a fringe
element but now it's catching momentum
how much do you know and you can tell us
about this third temple movement
do you know much about it yes we do
because we have been hearing that since
we were kids that
were talking about it and they're trying
to scare the arabs with that
yeah we but it's it's it's a real case
they are digging under the the al-aqsa
mosque and they are digging under the
jerusalem area
uh this is a conspiracy theory now this
is not like people making this up this
is actually happening you're
no your settlers are speaking settlers
are speaking about that
honestly the israeli government is
trying to do that honestly
uh if there was the cause of the
mosque which is a mosque in the in the
arab in the muslim quarter
next to al-aqsa was they tried for a
year to take that mosque out of the
herbs and to put
settlers in there then that's why
they're trying to bring the settlers all
the time in there to
make them earn a spot with the time so
the people at some day will stop
fighting
and will stop refusing that the settlers
be there they're trying to
force this thing on them so i
i believe that the israelis can do
anything me myself
they can do everything and they're
willing to do everything
in order to achieve their zionist view
on their
zionist idea we have an israeli and this
i'll end with this we have an israeli
professor
who's quoted as as staying this is
an academic historian that islam saved
the jury
and because often you'll hear the
statements that when you speak up they
try to
against not jewish people you know we
know there was a history can you tell us
also that
you know the like you were saying
earlier that the muslims welcomed the
jews
that when the jews were being persecuted
you know they came into muslim lands but
as soon as you talk about this
oppression about hey i want some
you know some rights some human rights
some dignity i want to live like a human
being
you know anybody who looks into this and
and has the humanness in them they just
people who have
who have come from all walks of life and
just come to visit that area they see
the injustices but as soon as you start
to speak up and talk out they label you
with this term anti-semitic
but it's interesting you're semitic
right
you you follow a prophet who's somatic
you speak a specific language
how can how can you be anti-semitic what
do you say to that
well that what you should know that's
like a great joke for us the
arab people speaking when we speak
politics like that
the same question that you're asking now
we always ask but the idea is that we
are controlled so much by the propaganda
and by the
yani this the people who support our
israel are
are the people who are are setting the
terms for politically correct
uh words and uh
and speeches and talks so the we are
cement
we are or we are the sun the sons of of
abraham
alhamdulillah and we and when it comes
to peace because
i don't believe in that version of
anti-semitism because i'm semitic in the
first place so we always answer that to
the israelis if we are in discussions
even though they bring the cops with
them to the discussions but uh
what we talk about more more than the
anti-semitism part
for me i think that they use that abroad
a lot much more than what they
that they use that here because they
know the truth
uh about cemeteries and israelis but
abroad it's like that
their their first defense line in
propaganda against everybody who speaks
on israel
what's the connection between israel and
and the the real judaism just today i
was
uh i was in another panel with uh
naftali carter
rabbi who was talking that israel is the
biggest menace and the biggest
uh crime that was done to judaism ever
so you were on another panel with
another rabbi yes
so you have a lot you have a lot of
israeli and jewish friends
not a lot but for me to have an israeli
jewish friend he should believe
on the rights of palestinians to liberty
and their historical rights on their
lands that he should take apart
in the fight if he's here yeah annie for
me i don't i don't find
any uh i i wouldn't find any right for
an israeli for a jewish guy to be here
in israel except if he's fighting the
fight of the palestinians
he is the strong part and he oh he owes
the palestinians a lot
so we believe in people who believe in
justice we believe in people who believe
in peace
but but peace doesn't come by by
crushing the
the weak the weak side and we have been
weakened for 70 years
and more as palestinians
yeah so concluding now if anybody we've
had people
who just recommended that you know when
when politicians from here when
christians because
it's not even palestinians who are
christians are being oppressed is that
right
true so true so
the christians from here uh who
want to visit they want to get a taste
of it for themselves
politicians from here i mean are they
more than welcome that i
wouldn't it be fair and balanced that
we've heard people
advise them just come to the other side
come visit the palestinians and come
talk to us
are you willing to talk there was only
one thing sorry then for cutting there
was only one thing that nasdale said
right in the bedouin video is that the
bedouin people are very hospitable
and they invite people to their homes
and that's something that all
palestinians and arabs share
we love inviting people and we love
talking to people and
we don't ask people for stuff that's
something that we have been learning
that since we were kids
and hospitality is a main part of our
society
uh i think people should come here and
see and when they come and see
and not go and they should listen from
the arabs and they should go to the
streets
because th this is a cause of human
values of the first place the
palestinian court
um we're not trying to look as victims
but this is the situation that is here
we we deserve we believe in our pride
and we
and the whole our the whole thing that
for me myself
that i believe in and i want i'm
fighting for uh
and i'm advocating for is my pride and
my people's pride in the first place
uh i believe that people who are
interested
people who want to hear their story and
before somebody says
one word out of propaganda and what he
hears in the news about the israeli
uh what they call the
israeli-palestinian conflict and we call
and we know it's occupation
is to come and see and visit to see the
wall in the west bank to see what's
happening in laksa
she don't recognize villages to see the
killing of people in the earth of
palestinians of the 48th and what's
happening to them
uh one one question that you asked
before about the history
and how the islam said the jews and how
we treat
the islams treated the jews it's very
important to mention that
the first time after islam that we the
the muslims entered the al-aqsa muslims
we're not talking about palestinians
that were here before but the
muslims that islam when came from
al-jazeera at the time
it was vulnerable the third khalifa of
islam
the second khalifa of islam uh when he
came to al-aqsa he made the deal
with the christians of laksa and with
the people of al-aqsa all of them with
all religions
it's called it's
an it's uh he gave them the protection
uh that this is something that continued
through all
the the islamic states after
allah was was a main law and base
to dealing with people who are not and
also quran before
to deal with people who are not muslim
you would never touch their worshipping
places you will never
judge them for something they didn't
know you would never persecute them for
religion or
try to make them leave their religion
whoever wanna
whoever is convinced by islam for
example he can go to islam
but but you wouldn't force anyone to do
anything that they don't want you you
wouldn't even force them to fight in the
islamic army when you have
another country attacking you or
something like that so it's a very i
think people should read about
and should really go to the islamic and
arabic history
to know how it was here it was always
peace uh
everybody was giving their place to to
pray for example for christians
didn't pray inside the church the church
from the resurrection church
because he didn't want the muslims with
the history to come and pray in his
spot and then he said
which is to come and be crowded it's
going to be crowded for you
guys and yeah one of the things people
will not
touch or break or harm your crosses for
example or your
or your churches or whatever so yeah
thank you so much for spending some time
with us so you do have even holocaust
survivors jewish holocaust survivors who
are speaking out against this
i've you know dr mattak i don't know if
you've heard of him
then you have uh other people your
friend
our friend uh doc uh mikko pillaid so
also what's his name elon poppy elon
poppe
docker dr fickelstein
norman fickenstein yeah i think i heard
the name yeah
yeah who else there is there is a lot
yeah you just maybe you should google
just yeah so this is all
right no this is not a jewish muslim
thing this is the truth thing this is
about
the humanness you know human rights
people who just want the basic human
rights that you and i get to have
every single day and i hope that with
god almighty's
help god almighty allah this can be
achieved
and anything else you want to close with
and if people want to visit they want to
visit down there
and they want to see for themselves they
don't want to go to disneyland this year
they want to come down and they want to
see for themselves what's going on
they're sick of the lies the propaganda
uh what do you recommend people are
welcome in the first place i would
always invite people to all mock up
to to my to my place and to my
to our living place to our areas we love
we love when people visit and we love
when people
want to learn and we respect everybody
who want to know the truth
and we feel that the israel propaganda
is lying to everybody
everywhere so uh most most of the work
today is trying to uncover the truth and
tell people
about what's really happening here
because people have been lied to for
for decades uh we we invite people
everywhere and they know that every
other palestinian activist invites
people to
come visit in bethlehem and here in the
west bank and then look up in the 48th
people um share many nightmare stories
is it very difficult do they have to if
they wanted to come they're watching the
dean show they say hey i'm gonna
go ahead and visit experience this but
is it very challenging i heard people
getting
you know uh going through so many
checkpoints and being
uh held for days like what's the process
of someone if they wanted to come to
that area and visit
is it i think for for americans and for
for people with the foreign
nationalities not arab people not muslim
people
you should just come to the airport show
them that you are pro israeli speak
pro-israeli language
and then for me for example as an arab
and there's a dark skin yeah they were
just i would go myself to the room that
dark room in the airport that they will
check me and they treat you as an arab
at the
case but people can come here and just
you should come as a tourist today like
you should say that you are touring and
don't show your real ideas and thoughts
when you are coming here or getting out
thank you so much jazakallah thank you
for sharing all that with us
my